[Music]
when it comes to competing at the
highest level in esports
confidence
can be key well it's pulled everyone
away from stewie he's the only one here
first shot is his second shot is his
bomb is his as well and he's got another
one stewie just tears them all down
it's stewie to ignite team liquid in the
second half not having enough self
belief at the right moment can mean the
difference between a monumental victory
and a soul-crushing defeat have to check
this on the pistol round glaive it's
gotta be the one to do so they're gonna
overlook it this is a massive chance
missing shots though disco he's gotta
hit those
it's a panic at the disco because he
can't get anything glaive's gonna put
him down but on the other hand having
too much faith in your ability can
definitely bite you in the ass
make it happen
it's going on
and perhaps in all of cs go no one has
deftly navigated the line between
confidence and overconfidence quite like
owen smooya butterfield a prodigious but
enigmatic talent from the land of tea
and crumpets who has made his name
flexing on fools with good old big green
out but the other two are still just
emerging right now oh no
swinging up well he's got a kill at
least now he's got two cases from going
down of course he can
really hard to find the bomb in that
situation and samia will make up for it
by uh pretty much taking out everybody
else but the thing about smooya is that
the unshakable self-belief that's made
him so dangerous on the server has also
caused his cs go career a lot of
problems off of it i was an 18 19 year
old kid telling everyone to [ __ ] off
because i thought nothing could happen
to me so how is it that smoothie has
recovered from a somewhat severe case of
self-inflated ego how did he try to make
up for the bridges he burned on his
meteoric rise to the top tier of
counter-strike
and now that he's finally landed on a
top-tier roster for the first time in
two years
what exactly are they signing up for
compete me i dare you come to me
[Applause]
pick me
[Music]
okay so before we dive into the story of
this mad lad please like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications oh also please be sure to
check out our brand new shorts channel
where you're going to get some dank
daily bite-sized content sometimes
starring yours truly
kids are still saying dank right all
right so if there is one thing you
should know about smooya it's that he's
a bit of a character he's not exactly
afraid of going against the grain the op
is a feared and respected weapon in
counter-strike its mere existence
changes how players navigate the map
being an opera also requires you to be
to be good with other weapons anyone can
all
anybody can opt like it's really easy if
you're aiming in the right place you'll
kill people you know and like the weapon
he's become known for using smuya can be
obnoxiously loud
but long before he was shattering
eardrums and exchanging pleasantries
with the goat smuyo was just a
pint-sized tyke in huddersfield cutting
his gaming teeth in world of warcraft
but after playing through vanilla and
all the way up to warlords of draenor
smooya was first introduced to cs go by
his friends in 2014. now because of his
age you might assume that smuyo was just
unnatural from the get-go like just
ripping people apart on the server but
the truth
is actually a lot funnier than that
he was so bad that his friends kicked
him out of their gaming group on skype i
was like i'm so mad that these guys
remove me it's impossible i'm gonna get
better than them there's no way so
i grinded every day for one year got
worse
i thought this is [ __ ] impossible so
that i got a new computer and then i got
like global lead in two weeks out of
them all back
laugh at them
and then yeah now i'm here from there cs
go became smooya's end-all friends
school sports
everything took a back seat to his
all-consuming obsession with clicking
heads and i just played a lot man i
think it's just a mix of having quote
unquote the knack for it if you want to
call it that like the genetic or
whatever or the prodigy term and a lot
of hard work i mean i every team i've
played on i've had the most hours on and
i started the game six years later than
everyone it's i've played for six years
and i have nearly 14 000 hours so it
balances out at like 2.8 k 3k hours a
year which is roughly like 6.5 hours a
day since i bought it on steam now if
you know anything about cs go you'll
know that unlike the rest of their
neighbors the british counter-strike
scene is
let's say anything but thriving so when
smooya inevitably decided to start
playing cs for a living
his native country's prospects
weren't all that enticing we're ncs like
it's bad enough no we're looking at it
like we have
no one to teach us how to play but after
going pro playing on a number of
different teams in 2016 smooya got his
big break the following year when he
landed a spot on epsilon esports an org
that not only could offer him a salary
but had a history of developing young
european cs talent and it works out for
him oh my goodness
now during his time with epsilon smooya
did experience success in smaller b-tier
tournaments but he had bigger dreams
than that and in order to achieve those
big ambitions he needed to make
a big move so naturally when big
eventually came knocking suya threw
himself at the opportunity i was
literally like b-hopping around the room
like oh my god
you want to really watch me um
and i was like i was brought in like
yeah i'll let you know like
trying to act all
called my mum i think i'm joining big i
don't know what's happening but this is
crazy smooya always felt that he was
special that given the chance he'd be
able to do great things in cs go and
with berlin international gaming it
seemed like his time had finally arrived
in no man's land very difficult what the
hell was that smoother absolutely crazy
stuff yes firing off a warning shot he's
oh it's gonna be a difficult one he
needs some support here very nice start
there from spear this is the second one
knife comes out surely not and yes it
will be a frag for smoothie around there
by god b and that's all the chances
nothing needs to take him down up to
smear now in the one versus three just
two players left to go as he goes for
the wide shots it connects one more to
find and he's good like i said earlier
smooya knew he had a gift but
unfortunately when you're in your late
teens getting paid to play the game you
love on international stages in front of
thousands of people and doing really
well at it that kind of knowledge can
really go to your head the god complex
started 18 years before then when i was
born
as i say i've always been a
better than most people in my classic
things and
when i no one in school tells you to fix
up and shut the [ __ ] up that leads to a
super arrogant toxic little kid
following biggs second place finish at
esl one cologne 2018 smooya's already
swelling sense of self-importance had
begun to really approach catastrophic
proportions the problem is that
smoothie's toxicity was a bit of a
catch-22 the better he performed the
more he felt like he had the right to
dump on other players leading people to
accuse him of being a conceited little
[ __ ] or worse and the more accusations
like these that smooya had to deal with
the stronger his need to lash out became
don't be super arrogant because even
though you think you're good within your
scene you're not good at cs at all like
literally at all because i've the reason
i actually eager is because i've just
been stomping noobs my entire life and
i'm pretty sure
it was just coming from a background
where everyone was already hating on me
saying that can't be anything and then i
did everything and then it was like
you all eventually that vicious
vindictive cycle landed smooya in hot
water in early 2019 after he admitted to
loba that he'd told optics refresh
something extremely unsavory during an
fpl match not only did it result in him
being temporarily banned from fpl but it
also saw him suspended from biggs active
roster after letting him play for a
variety of other rosters during his
suspension big brought him back into the
fold later that year but smooya still
proved to be a problem on top of
disagreeing with his teammates about
tactics a lack of feeling appreciated
led to him not giving it his all which
didn't exactly go down well with his
roster tabs and went yeah it's fine
we'll do better without you anyway and i
was like okay that's a very fair
statement to make like that's fine
that's on you if you don't want me to be
here just tell me it's like if you don't
want to be here then don't be here i
literally was like oh no like no please
ask me to stay like i said it wanted him
to ask me like no oh and stay we need
you and he was like just [ __ ] off when i
was like
smooya had effectively blown his big
break but he still wanted to compete
more than anything so with limited
options available to him in europe
smooya decided to try his hand at
the dumpster fire that is nacs
but even finding a home there proved to
be difficult so i wanted to go to na and
at the time cloud9 were rebuilding
scoodoodle just retired so i thought
that's they have to take me they cannot
take anyone else boom they take mix well
what the [ __ ] has just happened like
this is impossible now despite that
initial setback the land of gunfire and
freedom was still in smooya's sights and
so when chaos esports club offered him a
spot on their roster he packed up his
stuff and set out on his exciting
american adventure so i get the
destroy everyone for four months prove
that i was significantly better than all
the players that have now moved to varun
under the best players i was destroying
all of them
day in day out fpl officials whatever
you want to call it online offline they
all caught these hands over pass and
dust too
are
both really decent affairs for them
yeah it's even a collapse on the floor
he is just
hitting his stride
whoa
what a beautiful second shot
yeah boost some shots going through and
actually doing a fair bit of damage
there's an incoming t-side smoother will
open up and taking down throw and he's
rushing through still got a couple of
walls enough for a headshot oh turn
around
what a triple kill and man and taco i
don't know that is so outrageous make it
a quad kill for smoothie why not but of
course just as things were finally
starting to go smooya's way
coveted hit north america
hard in march of 2020. unfortunately for
him he'd gone back to england to renew
his visa that month and thanks to the
implementation of travel restrictions
his time on chaos came to an abrupt end
then i spent
two months feeling sorry for myself
getting depressed the usual stuff
then i went to the gym got my head in
shape lost a little bit of fat and then
i said [ __ ] this [ __ ] i need to play so
bad my competitive itch is killing me
i'm gonna rifle i don't care i don't
care what it takes i need to play in the
team because
i can't wake up at 6 00 pm any longer i
need some form of schedule in my life i
can't take this luckily for smooya's
sanity contact gaming just happened to
be looking for a rifler so he linked up
with them but you gotta understand
something here the choice to rifle
was a big compromise for smooya this was
a guy who built his entire career around
the op so by taking up a rifler's role
with contact
smuyo was settling and that's never a
good thing can someone tell me in what
dimension we're living where and the
highest rated player on that team
rifling playing a [ __ ] lurk role on t
sides and a [ __ ] anchor position
in what dimension are we living in but
as you might expect smooya's stint in
his new role with contact proved to be
very brief he ended up joining the
spanish side that was movie star riders
and moved back into his natural position
manning the op where for the most part
he did great although his attitude
wasn't entirely without question forced
to come back through the molly they go
he's running through his own molly 21
28 to 1 hp
mo mopa's alone they are leaving the
server
mopas it's a 1v
3 it's doable and his own teammate left
i want to see him do it i'm not leaving
the server
18 seconds
and supra
will go hunting the flick will miss mo
puzzle drop oh 10 hp 10 seconds oh
homopods will do it he shows up his
teammates now smuya defended himself by
stating that his pc had crashed but
because of his checkered history as a
teammate not everyone was willing to
give him the benefit of the doubt i
completely get the concerns of can we
trust him here he left this server
without his teammate clutching he did
this he did that
barring this one incident with more
players and movie star riders there has
not been a negative thing about me on
twitter read it for two years ultimately
communication issues brought smoothie's
time on movie star to a close
but not in the way you'd expect the team
simply decided to transition to an
all-spanish roster leaving an emotional
smooya who by the way was by far their
best player looking for other
opportunities and so in august of 2021
with no enticing competitive options on
his plate smooya decided to dive head
first into streaming i'll buy a dildo
stick it on the wall right here every
five gifted i'll suck it
starting right now
holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] is
that thing
it looks tiny it's absolutely massive do
you guys see that
wait
lol
look it's huge
i killed sure
thanks to his natural charisma his knack
for creating highlights and some of the
company he kept smooya was able to build
and grow a twitch audience in no time
but as much as he enjoyed going live
every night his drive to compete
never waned and thanks to his improved
behavior and consistently impressive
individual performances in fpl
smuya would in fact get another chance
in the top tier in october of this year
fnatic reached out to smooya to stand in
for their bid to qualify for iem winter
2021 and off the back of that success
extended to him an invitation to join
their roster on a three-month trial
nearly two years after getting the big
boot and feeling like he might never get
another crack at playing top tier cs
smooya now finds himself on one of the
most prestigious orgs in the game's
history and has vowed to make the most
of his shot at redemption can't wait to
see you at tier one again keep killing
it for the three months thank you very
much bro for being the first
subscription under my fanatic time
thank you very much bro i've got some
making the team but don't choke you
should know me by now bro i don't choke
smooya might be outspoken he might be
loud and he might be unpredictable on
and off the server but those
characteristics in combination with the
obvious talent he possesses make him
someone worth keeping an eye on at least
that's what simple seems to think in
fact since smooya's return to tier 1
competitive counter-strike he and his
game's goat have developed something of
an on-stream rivalry one which isn't so
much hostile as it is wholesome and well
hilarious
i can't hear you simple
i can't hear you
regardless of whether it works out for
samuya with fnatic specifically at 22
years of age he still has plenty of time
to prove that he's overcome his ego and
can be relied on both as a player and as
a teammate and if his recent behavior
and willingness to look in the mirror
and own his past mistakes is proof of
anything it's that he might finally be
ready to show the world of
counter-strike
what exactly it is they've been missing
british esports is shite what the [ __ ]
you want me to say like
there's like three people in the whole
of esports who come from england and
like our top tier in a game chrome pits
and tea i like tea i like japanese tea i
don't really like english tea crumbs are
good with like
if you eat them like pancakes like if
you put butter and maple syrup on them
they're good